the Chinese president's gigantic plane
touches down in Moscow where he's met
slightly strangely by one of Russia's
Deputy Prime Ministers not the most
senior government figure for such a key
diplomatic moment
then on to the Kremlin Ten Years After
he made his first trip here on assuming
the Chinese presidency
two men have met more than 40 times
since then bonded by trade geography and
a mutual dislike of the United States
foreign
Putin's indictment on war crimes charges
not of concern here but Ukraine will be
discussed China Keen to position itself
as it would be peace broker
it is
rotation courses
President Putin is just back from a trip
to mariupo his first visit to the
Ukrainian territories he now claims on
his own hardly a good starting point for
talks and the U.S says it is unconvinced
by President xi's calls for a ceasefire
the world should not be fooled by any
tactical move by Russia supported by
China or any other country to freeze the
war on its own terms
as spring begins to break through the
horrors of War are still a long way off
ERS
do you think Russia is isolated
foreign
Xi Jinping is expected to place a call
to the Ukrainian president once his trip
to Moscow is done
there is nothing even-handed about a
three-day State visit to Moscow followed
by possibly just a telephone call with
Vladimir zielinski if president XI was
serious about pushing for peace you'd
have thought he might pass by Kiev too
but that seems unlikely One Step too far
for this apparent No Limits friendship
Diana McNeese Sky News Moscow